des décors de rêve à couper le souffle
les plages de cavendish à
l'île-du-prince-édouard révèle encore un
peu plus leur beauté vue du ciel filmée
par un drone mais attention seuls
quelques privilégiés spécialement permis
par parcs canada sont autorisés à le
faire car les drones sont interdits dans
tous les parcs nationaux au pays
[Musique]
nous avons une importante hausse d
utilisation illégale de drones dans le
parc souligne cette garde de parc
les infractions qui se multiplient
accroît le danger pour la nature ainsi
que pour les visiteurs et pour faire
diminuer les risques
parcs canada a instauré des amendes
allant de 575 à 25000 dollars et les
risques d'amande sont plus nombreux
depuis le début du mois
en effet depuis le 1er juin transports
canada resserrer les règles entourant
l'autorisation des drones en plus de
l'immatriculation de l'appareil
un examen est aujourd'hui obligatoire
l'objectif est d'éduquer les
utilisateurs de drones à summerside
watson connaît parfaitement ses règles
ce président d'une entreprise de drones
réalise assez régulièrement des survols
de la province pour des organismes
gouvernementaux
pour lui les règles sont la base mais
pas uniquement
ce n'est pas qu'un test vous devez
comprendre l'espace est rien ce que vous
pouvez vous ne pouvez pas faire avec
votre drones explique-t-il
de plus lit dodson a su rencontrer de
nombreux utilisateurs hors la loi
aujourd'hui il réclame plus d'éducation
de la part de parcs canada aux visiteurs
et davantage selon lui aux personnes
venant d'autres pays
éducation oui mais par canada doit
installer des panneaux dansaient par une
demande entendue par les responsables de
parcs canada
des panneaux seront installés durant
l'été en attendant les informations sur
l'utilisation des drones sont présents
sur son site internet
des brochures sont aussi distribués à
l'entrée des parcs ici je ne le cachera
du canada charlottetown